Let's go next to Gabe from London. Across
the pond. Gabe, what's going on over there?
Hello.
Yes, please. Please, if you can.
We're hearing the little discord beeps.
Is there any way you can mute those?
I'm sorry. I've done them.
Anyway, aides say it's great
speaking to you, I'm such a big fan. My question
is pretty simple, which is off the election.
What can be done? Do you think, to stop a massive
amount of misinformation we see from places like
Fox News, even mainstream places like that?
The problem is that it's very hard. I mean, I'm
going to take and I'm going to answer it,
Off-line, because the discord beeping is
people are furious about it. I'm not. But other
people get furious. The problem really is that
in terms of regulation, there's very little you
can do to stop people from believing Fox News.
Right. I mean, it's like you could say, let's try
to pull Fox News off the air. I don't see how you
do it. And that's just not what this country is
is built on. So you need to essentially just have,
like, smarter people who understand who have
a better understanding of media literacy
and have the tools they need to protect
themselves from from disinformation, who
know how to question a story, who understand how
to research whether they're being told something
that's true or not. Who can distinguish between
news and opinion programing. So unfortunately,
I wish there was something that could be done
to fix the Fox News problem. But based on the
legal infrastructure of this country, I don't
see how you do it. And it's really a matter of
having people who can better protect themselves
from the disinformation. And that's pretty,
pretty damn difficult does as we've experienced.